works of art can be perplexing and
sometimes they can knock you dead
Netflix velvet buzzsaw takes that idea
and runs with it giving life to pieces
of art that might take your breath away
permanently if you're having trouble
figuring out what the film is trying to
say worry no more as we break down the
bloody end of velvet buzzsaw don't be
fooled by the glossy Sheen despite a
high art atmosphere a generous budget
and a cast stacked with a listers at its
hearts velvet buzzsaw is as trashy a
horror movie as any installment of
Friday the 13th but as far as plot goes
the movie can be more accurately
described as an art world version of
final destination instead of the victims
being generally unsympathetic
cookie-cutter teens they're uniquely
loathsome insufferably pretentious grown
adults you're flat-out not supposed to
like them which makes it all the more
exciting when the time comes to sit back
and watch them suffer much like final
destination this is essentially a
slasher movie with a metaphysical
villain in the final destination series
the enemy is death itself in velvet
buzzsaw things are a little bit more
complicated here the killer is the
vengeful spirit of a deceased artist
persisting from beyond the grave to
lethally punish those who would seek to
prop it off of his or others art if it
sounds a little silly that's because
it's supposed to be velvet buzzsaw is
not a particularly scary movie as far as
genre goes it's best to describe it as a
horror comedy with the emphasis on
comedy but it's not a very funny movie
either
as far as knee-slapping jokes are
concerned above all else the movie is a
satire about bad people it's humor comes
from the absurdity of the characters and
their ridiculous world which they all
take quite seriously think about the
characters names which take
pretentiousness to the point of parody
there's more van waltz road Dora Hayes
John Don Don and of course the vengeful
artists petrol Dee's all of these people
are insufferable at best and evil at
worst generally only caring about
themselves with characters like this the
movies world is already a total Horror
Show making the killings extra cathartic
a key to understanding the movie is
realizing that it's not really trying to
frighten you when these characters get
what's coming to them you're
supposed to be amused some of the first
lines of dialogue in velvet buzzsaw come
from a mechanized artwork called hobo
man a mixed-media piece on display at
Parque Basel Jake Gyllenhaal's Critic
character more has arrived to size up
the piece as well as whatever else
catches his eye at the show have you
have a fountain visible the question
appears to be commenting on homeless
people but it also applies to velvet
buzzsaws conception of the artist as
well as the bitter grudge that drives
the movies story along for a movie about
the art world very few artists actually
appear most of the characters are at
these shows to buy sell hype up or
reject art the artists themselves are
spoken of like brand names with their
work being praised for its popularity
and monetary value above all else
they're not treated like people who put
their hearts and souls into their
creations especially the artists at the
center of the plot morph determines the
value of art by filtering it all through
his own perspective what he doesn't like
doesn't sell he may not be a gallery
owner or an outright sellout like red
aura but he's still a gatekeeper and a
crucial part of the art world ecosystem
when morph walks into the Art Basel show
at the start of the movie he passes by a
sign that reads there's no confusion in
my house a statement that reflects his
status as a critic confusion only exists
in morphs personal life when he's at
work he speaks with exacting certainty
morph is there to pass judgment in his
world it's up to him to determine what
qualifies as quality art he dismisses
the hit of the show
hobo man as a derivative work that
doesn't impress him his assessment
effectively cancels out all other praise
leading the piece to languish and
storage after his bad reviews snuffs out
all interest in it your review of how a
man killed the Sam
instead of being seen it's gathering
dust to destroy society I am NOT your
mouthpiece Wars critiques have direct
consequences with some bad reviews
apparently being so distressing that
they basically threaten artists lives in
one instance warp is told about an
artist through tail spins into
self-destruction after being emotionally
devastated by one of his brutal reviews
Riki got drunk and crashed his car last
night he's in coma I heard he was
crushed panic on your review in the
world of velvet buzzsaw Moore's
critiques are presented as a kind of
violence justifying his own eventual
death at the hands of the living hobo
man velvet buzzsaw positions itself as a
critique of the commercialization of art
with a vengeful spirits of ventral Dee
serving as the messages main vessel but
it's important to remember that Dee's
himself was not a particularly good
person as Morphin the other characters
eventually discover dese was very
violent and emotionally disturbed death
didn't turn him into a killer spirit it
really just led his Dark Soul loose on
the world despite all of this it seems
that everything would have been fine if
Josefina had just followed desus wishes
man allowed his work to be destroyed
usually blaming the victim is a nasty
thing in the context of velvet buzzsaw
in which the victims are pretty much
always operating out of their own
self-interest
it feels pretty justified the killer is
a bad person sure but there are no
innocent victims in this movie as
haunting as deesis paintings appear it's
not necessarily his artwork that's
carrying a curse sure his actual blood
may be all mixed up with the paint he
used but that's more a signpost for the
movies themes than a key to its twisted
magic the actual function of deesis
curse is to weaponize all art not just
his own paintings that's why hobo man
comes to life to attack more why Speer
is able to cut Gretchen's arm off in the
movies best kill and why Josefina gets
consumed by a roomful of living paint
the movie doesn't explain its rules very
well but the unifying thread of all the
deaths is that they're committed by
works of art against people who see art
as little more than something to be
bought and sold
with these characters being so steeped
in the art world they're always
vulnerable
they don't appreciate the power that
surrounds them and end up paying for
their ignorance with their lives after a
few kills have been tallied up this
message becomes really really obvious
but the killings aren't as simple as
selling art equals you die they're more
of an indictment of people's whole
philosophies the plunder of deesis
paintings results in multiple deaths
Bryson the gallery installer who steals
some of the artwork John the gallery
owner whose body KOCO finds Gretchen
whose body
KOCO finds Josefina whose greedy desire
to raise her status as an exhibitor led
her to steal deesis art in the first
place and morph the destructive critic
whose body cocoa also finds or cocoa
[Music]
morph spends most of the movie getting
increasingly suspicious about the many
deaths happening around him but the only
character to figure out what's going on
is ridore a-- after Bryson John Gretchen
Josefina and morph all die ridore a--
accepts at the insane scenario of des
bringing art to life to kill people
probably has some merit to it sensing
that she's probably next on the chopping
block red aura hires a team of movers to
strip her home of all artwork every
image every drawing every postcard
counting up to 47 pieces in total
satisfied that the job is done she
starts the rest more easily until she
feels a little tickle on the back of her
neck The Velvet buzzsaw tattoo a band
logo from her Dora's days as a punk
musician is one piece of art she
couldn't get rid of leaving her helpless
as it grinds to life to kill her dead at
the beginning of the movie rad auras old
band is implied by the artist and
reached to have started from a sincere
place before losing the plot presumably
becoming more of a brand name in a way
of making money than a purely artistic
outlet basically she's a sellout and she
knows it
yeah the early stuff was great then it
became what like self-parody
dan rish been only six months removed
from a life of poverty is still in tune
with his creative roots and acutely
sensitive to the idea of selling out a
path rad or committed to long ago for
the sake of getting rich it's a decision
that ultimately dooms her guiding her
directly over the years to a most
unexpected
death there's a moment at the beginning
of Velvet buzzsaw in which John
Malkovich's character and artist named
piers expresses a desire to get away
from the tiresome circus of art as
business and returned to something pure
when we meet him at Art Basel he's
successful sober and creatively
unsatisfied he seems to be unhappy and
his state of mind is a key thing to keep
in mind as you unpack the movie's themes
I am fighting to get back to creation to
revelation the billion years of energies
sparking to Herr Brent as the movie
eventually concludes this path is a
righteous one writer director Dan Gilroy
talked about the themes velvet buzzsaw
explores in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter saying I was very
interested in the idea of the
relationship between arts and commerce
in today's world it's a very uneasy
relationship that's not to say that
commercial success diminishes a work but
it doesn't define it either I wanted to
get at the idea that art is more than a
commodity ultimately the movie is about
elevating the pure act of creation over
crafts commercialization that's why the
man on the street at the movies end a
real hobo man isn't in any danger from
selling the DC art he finds following
Roe Dora's death sold for cheap on the
street the art is judged by pure
aesthetics not by perceived value Dee's
wanted his work destroyed but at the end
of the movie it's out in the world
anonymously which also seems to be an
acceptable fate his body of work is no
longer an eight-figure batch of
commodities but once again pieces of art
for art's sake velvet buzzsaw expresses
its themes not just through the people
it kills but also by the people it
doesn't pour coco who stumbles across so
many of the movies dead bodies never
gets a higher level job that she's so
covets because of the distance she
maintains from the art industry's rotten
mortal core she survives theses wrath
damn rish haunted by gazing into a deist
painting and feeling as though it's
watching him just gets up and leaves the
movie at one point sensing the danger
and running for his life
as for peers he goes hermit and starts
drinking again surviving out of his
desire to get away from the alienating
commercial side of the art business it's
an amusing message for the movie to
commit to but it really does go there
going back to being a drunk
Storrs Pierce's creativity and basically
saves his life nothing silver hasn't
been good for him well this was done 15
years ago Pierce was in the full bloom
of alcoholism err exactly in letting
these three characters survive the movie
is saying that they're all on the
correct paths in the final shot of the
movie beneath the credits piers walks on
a beach
scratching shapes into the sand with a
stick and close-up it seems as though
there could be some bigger message on
what he's doing but as the camera pans
back it becomes clear that there's no
deeper meaning to his drawings he's
creating just for fun his colleagues
made art into something to consume and
so got consumed by it Pierce goes back
to basics seeking that primal creative
energy he ends the movie looking drunk
and joyful with his life intact
performing for no one in particular
drawing aimless circles on the beach
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stopper coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]